l'économiste david beck dans l'aude du
centre canadien de politiques
alternatives qu'on plus qu'un modèle
pancanadien par nationale donc de
soutien financier au service de garde
pour enfants devrait être déployée et
s'inspirer de l'exemple donné québécois
les villes on trouve les faits les clips
qui sont dans les combats sont là des
frais fixés par le gouvernement
provincial
mais aussi le manitoba et l'île du
prince édouard dans l'étude publiée par
le centre canadien des politiques
alternatives toronto était de loin la
ville la plus chère au pays avec un coût
supérieur à 1000 $ par enfant par mois
et alors pour un touriste chance et 1649
en a pour tous petits as et 1375 alors
époux rentrée scolaire c'est le cas du
riz le plus commun à ces 1000 à 6150
d'alors fils de québec
les frais sont sont environ 200 dhs
alors quand c'est beaucoup beaucoup
moins faire pour les ja pour la classe
moyenne
certes l'état québécois participent plus
aux efforts de manière générale des
familles
mais les taxis sont aussi beaucoup plus
élevé qui a si on inclut les subventions
là on trouve le camp opposé alors à
toronto c'était ce qui est assez
chanceux de recevoir une subvention pour
pour les garderies ça te coûte seulement
90 dollars pour un enfant dans le
préscolaire a lancé moins cher qu'au
québec parc au québec qui oppose
suspension pour les familles avec faible
revenu la gestion des services de garde
dans le reste du canada est en situation
de crise au niveau des listes d'attentes
qui sont légion à travers le pays dans
toutes les villes on retrouve au moins
60% des cendres qui ont une liste
d'attentes à toronto
ce sont 99 pour cent dix ans
l'acceptabilité qu'attend par l'activité
car tellement que le prêt est un facteur
majeur et particulièrement la région de
toronto les coûts sont très élevés
martin saintonge la directrice générale
de l'association francophone à
l'éducation des services à l'enfance de
l'ontario
elle estime qu'il serait impossible sans
des subventions gouvernementales
supplémentaire de concilier service de
qualité et prix abordables pour tous les
citoyens à la base d'équations
mathématiques magique dans le sens où
que ce soit les terres lys entre les
organise comme tels que soient financés
pour leur fonctionnement que ce soit les
parents qui soient financés pour payer
leurs frais que ce soient des
subventions qui vont aux parents par
exemple ayant des revenus un moyen est
beau peu importe la formule tout peu
aidé par cas la balle avec tous avec
tous les changements qui ont lieu dans
le secteur de l'absence hante le
changement de loi
la nouvelle pédagogie les coûts
d'opération si on veut de la qualité
sont très élevés la seule façon de
diminuer le coût pour le parent c'est
très certainement de dd en finançant le
secteur d'une façon du nom parce que si
on regarde ailleurs que ce soit ailleurs
au canada et ailleurs dans le monde la
petite enfance et reconnu maintenant
tous les recherches le prouve c'est un
moment crucial dans le développement
d'un être humain
il faut y mettre des ressources si on
dit que c'est une valeur importante pour
nous comme société pour que nos citoyens
à 2 de toi puisse participer en terme à
la société de demain
c'est maintenant qu'il faut adapter le
taux d'activité des mères québécoises
ont considérablement augmenté puis à
l'institution du système il ya 20 ans à
l'heure actuelle taux d'activité des
femmes québécoises c'est le plus haut au
monde après celui déçu c'est speed et
des suédois
pierre fortin qui est économiste et
professeur à l'université du québec à
montréal à la cote au québec et c'est un
conférencier invité prise et dans le
reste du pays
essam ans il s'est déplacé dans l'ouest
pour donner une conférence à
l'université de lacombe britannique pour
parler justement du modèle québécois du
système de garderie un des problème qui
s'est posé c'est que malgré que le
système des cpe
et apporter beaucoup plus d'argent aux
coffres de l'état qui lui en écouter
pourquoi parce que avec tant de femmes
en plus dans la population active
ces femmes la paie des impôts
supplémentaires
despey de la tps des textes provincial
chez terreur et il rentre dans les
coffres de l'état fédéraux et
provinciaux
ottawa et québec obtienne les ses
revenus fiscaux là mais ses revenus
fiscaux là sont tellement importants
qu'ils dépassent le coût supplémentaire
que ce système là apportées au système
de garde au québec
donc on peut s'attendre on pourrait
s'attendre à ce que les garderies au
total soit un avantage l'air pour les
finances publiques lorsqu'il est
question de créer un monde du travail
qui serait plus ouvert et sympathique
aux réalités des femmes et des familles
avec ou sans enfants le canada semble
pour le moment en pleine gestation
un reportage de radio canada
international